hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to the eighth episode in the
serialization series so it's been a
while since the last one but I thought
that you know what let's wrap this
series up so over the next week or so
hopefully we'll be done with this so
last time I briefly mentioned something
about the fact that we should move on to
types right and being able to
essentially know what type we're about
to read so the way this currently works
and that you could probably guess that
from reading this code right we have the
ability to read and we know which read
method we should use right such as a
read inch read long read float read
double read bull we have string either I
mean we can encode strings of course as
char arrays which I don't think can we
even do that yeah well I mean we can
always just convert it into us into an
into a byte array and then write it
along with the size strings isn't
nothing we should do there anyway all
that aside what I was getting at was we
have the ability to read certain types
but if we're just looking at a stream of
bytes that is inside a file we need
something that tells us what type this
currently is okay I kind of look at the
sterilization series from and in general
sterilization and what we're
implementing here as like almost like a
three step process right
the first kind of low-level the step I
guess is the actual data right those are
the bytes that we want to read into ram
into memory when we when we launch our
application for example step two so
that's kind of the actual like data
bytes then we have the kind of
descriptors right they tell us what what
type the data actually is so that we can
read the right amount of bytes and
interpret them into a type correctly and
they and the descriptor will also have
like a name or something that tells us
what data were actually you know storing
like for example is this supposed to be
the x position of the player
on the map right or is this supposed to
be the players name is this supposed to
be the width and height of the window
and then one more step backwards is kind
of the high-level overview of the actual
structure of this realization database
and that would mean things like you know
is it organized into objects like how I
how about all of these descriptors along
with their data how are all of them
arranged right how many objects are
there how many fields do each object the
disease object have right and if you go
back and watch some of the earlier
videos of course they did they did cover
a lot about like I drew diagrams and I
actually kind of showed you guys what
the format was going to look like and I
think I actually have to go back and
watch them because it's been so long and
I just don't think I remember exactly
what I said but we're gonna kind of just
go along with this and hopefully it'll
match up but anyway that kind of covered
all the kind of high-level overview with
fields and objects and arrays and all of
that stuff okay cool so let's talk about
the types today how do we write a type
so what I like doing and this is
actually a little bit difficult to do in
Java it's actually surprisingly well
somewhat surprisingly a lot easier to
get this done in C++ because C++ is a
low-level language which is perfect for
this kind of stuff so as C by the way in
Java it's it's a bit of a bit of a drag
but usually what I would do is I would
declare some kind of struct right and
when you do when you declare a struct in
something like C you can actually just
look up all the data that's in this
dropped in memory and then you can just
kind of grab it all like immediately and
it's already available to you as a byte
array because that's how it's stored in
memory and you have that kind of direct
access to memory which you don't in Java
so that's why this is gonna be probably
a bit annoying but let's start off with
actually creating when I get some stuff
done today I promise you but let's just
start off with creating class that is
probably going to be something like a
field so
I'll be real simple with my naming I'm
gonna call this field okay so this this
class is actually pretend that this is
the actual representation like if you
were to print out a stream of bytes
which would make up this class that's
what we will see you know actual data in
our file
okay this get that gets serialized now
one thing I should mention is obviously
a serialization can be applied to more
than just like files right it's also
used for stuff like network streams and
in fact the reason we're doing this is
that the game programming does have that
multiplayer component so I'm just gonna
take files as an example so that I don't
have to say you know streams all the
time or something like that but just
obviously when I say that this is what's
gonna happen this is what its gonna look
like in our file I mean that what it's
actually going to look like in that
sterilisation stream okay so everything
is going to be public that's the first
step
everything is gonna be public because
there's no reason to write getters and
setters for absolutely everything this
is transparent data that we're simply
putting into a class for the purposes of
keeping it together okay if we could
avoid making classes that actually could
be an option as well and that probably
wouldn't be a very fun option but you
know you know we have to make classes
this is Java so we'll do something like
we have our data right so that's a byte
array that's our actual data for the
field we have to have a type which
describes the data this will probably be
a single byte I'll call this type or
data type we also need to make sure that
we have like a string again I'm I might
play around with the ordering of these
things but we will have we have to have
a string which we could probably convert
into a byte array straight away so this
would be like name and then we need to
have a short probably which is name
length
I imagine this could be a byte I mean I
doubt names are going to more be more
than 250 characters but um yeah we'll
keep it as short just for fun
so this is this is kind of like this is
basically all you need to describe a
field now this is a primitive field so
this isn't something like let me just
make sure that we've kind of we're on
the same page yeah that I haven't done
any of this no okay cool
it seems to be all that I have anyway
sorry has been so long I just don't
don't know around so we've been over
strings and how to store them right
usually you store a name let like you
usually you stole some kind of length
first and then the actual string there
are a few reasons as to why you there
are a few reasons as to why I don't like
storing a termination character at the
end some people like both is totally
fine if you want to do both if you just
want to do the termination character
without an actual length I find that
problematic just because it means that
you have to actually iterate through all
the bytes to find out where the string
ends you can't just grab you don't know
how many bytes you need to read right
which also means that if it's a very
very long script string that you know
might be I don't know a couple kilobytes
or something that you don't actually
want to read you can't make that
decision until you've gone through all
of it and checked every single byte to
see if it's a null termination character
or if it's zero so that I'm not a fan of
that I mean no one is really having a
termination character the end isn't the
worst idea because it means that you can
just you - you can just read in that
data immediately into memory and that's
that's that you don't have to add a
termination character it'll in later
that's fine but you know I just I guess
I save a byte of data every time I bite
of storage anyway
that's again details so what we'll do is
I guess yeah so I guess the first thing
when we encounter a field we should
probably know that it is a field so I'll
have something like a byte that says I
don't know what a couldest this will
basically be a
a data storage type right so for example
it could be a field that could be an
array it could be an object so fields of
course the things that you find inside
objects and arrays are lots of things
that you find inside objects and arrays
are usually made up of fields as in an
array is a field is a but like an array
would beat this component of a field
right you still have that like type and
then you have that name and then these
things are where you kind of get fancy
right instead of like the data type
which will be there instead of this data
you might also in an array literally
just have an integer which says element
count right and then you suddenly know
that hey I need to divide this data by
the amount of element count right so
every like if the data type was an int
and then we know that it int is four
bytes at least on the system we're
working on in fact that Ruby on all
systems right there's a Java if an int
is four bytes and we have eight imps or
something like that right we know the
data every single every single four
bytes of data needs to get put into its
own in it's like it is its own element
yeah and of course that will just that
was a result in us having 32 bytes of
data here and then they kind of get put
into there each one of them gets
inserted into a and indexed in an
integer array so that's an example of
how we would implement a race but we're
doing fields right now so let's stick
with that that's what this really is so
I should probably call this data storage
type and then we have the name length
and then we have the name and you have
the data type I mean the daughter I
think I'm pretty happy with that I'll I
will make a setname method here just for
convenience and this will just let us do
a few things first of all it will mean
that we do something like this dot so
we'll copy this into memory first I'm
not sure if we should do that hang on
let me just if we go name get bytes what
is that actually doing
in a new bio right okay so that's rude
allocate storage for us automatically
and then so we set the name to that and
then of course the name line can be set
to name dot length okay and that's done
that's done and we can Kyle's head into
a short if we were really cool as well I
don't like I mean we have pretty cool so
I guess we'll do this we'll just make
sure the name the length is actually
less than the max size all the max value
to show up right which should be like 30
mm because it's signer okay this is just
us making sure that we're kind of can be
stored in a short I mean this should
never happen I don't imagine we'll ever
have a string that is more than 32,000
characters in an actual data oriented
kind of civilization format all right
this isn't like a Word document
and even if that even if it was we
wouldn't be storing everything in a
single array
anyway the point is let's that's pretty
much all that's pretty much all we have
for a field okay now the next thing
we'll do is probably create one of these
so there are two things we need to
define here the datatype and a daughter
storage type I might actually just call
this container type I think that might
be a better name so we have the
container type and we have the data type
we could even just call this type okay
we need a definition of all of these so
I'm just trying to why should I put
these let's see content types maybe
container type yeah all right we'll make
separate classes for phase I mean I
would probably just make a bunch of
classes in one file but since we know we
can't do that either
looks like we're dude we're doing this
instead
what am I just doing a new project
that's great that's great
all right type so we've got container
type and type so container type will
have something like public static bytes
objects nickels like one will probably
usually want to make these I'll make
something like unknown or something and
that's zero so that can be used as like
an arrow state okay and then we have
objects when I start at the beginning
all right we'll have filled array will
be separate right because these are in
closing time no no no we still have
these because they describe the
immediate data that follows array and
object okay and then I'll just kind of
align these and set them off as two and
three okay pretty simple they can never
be both like you we can't have something
that is both a field and a right like an
array is a field so we don't need to
make like a bit field or anything out of
this so zero one two three it should be
fine if we go into type this is where
this gets more fun I also want to have a
public static what should we do
imply yes yes sighs I mean this it
doesn't have to be an end and then what
this will do is basically based on a
certain type it will just return us
returned to us what size how many saw
like what the size is in bytes right all
right that'll be useful
so we'll do unknown I guess we'll just
start at the bottom right it will say
bytes short yeah I guess what just char
which is the same as a show up but it's
unsigned int
it's the alignment is a bit annoying or
we have long is that it struggling to
think that's it I think that's what we
have in Java in terms of the integer
types okay then we have float and double
those are our decimal types and then we
have bullying
is that it
bullying double float long int char
short bite I believe that's it in terms
of primitive types string is probably a
completely different beast that I want
to tackle
later on we'll cover strength separately
because they require separate coverage
and then what this will do is it will
look at the type and if the type is kind
of this work again do we just have to do
oh sorry this should be a bite all right
yeah okay that why would you do that if
it's unknown I guess we can like assert
or something and are like yeah it just
kind of must be constant expressions
okay well I mean yeah I guess that's a
good good signal for us to actually make
them constant expressions related to get
to make the final same with the
container types as well
okay so yeah we'll just assert to make
sure that we're in trouble
bytes these are going to be these are
going to be one line statements return
one okay let's make a bunch of these
short Chow int long float double and the
lame so boolean's again I did talk about
packing last time we're not going to
worry about that too much I think I will
just make the one buy it I mean we do a
set up so we can just return negative
one on something um or zero that'll be
bad
okay so let's we can just leave that
alone
okay so short two two four eight
oops four eight and one okay so this is
just a little conversion chart I don't
know if Java has this actually I'm kind
of used to doing this stuff in C++ which
of course doesn't have anything like
that so I wonder if I could probably
just do something like integer dot size
yeah okay I mean that's probably better
isn't it let's just take a look at what
that value actually is oh really
all right it's quickly - sauce here and
take a look at size 30 juice was in bits
so yeah I it's okay
we know that the sizes like this we're
going to assume that this doesn't change
it might in 10 years in 20 years and 100
years but I'm sure this it's fine okay
cool so there we go we've got a bunch of
types now that's good and we know what
size each type is and then we've got a
bunch of container types as well so now
the process is really simple every one
of these classes that we have filled
right because we can't simply access
these dis data as a stream of singular
data especially because we do have a
raise which means that these are
actually stored in a different location
in memory to save these so I'm assuming
Java would probably also store this in a
row so we might we might have something
like container type and
like the net literally the next bite so
the offset of a field instance plus one
bite would be the beginning of name
length plus three bites would be the
beginning of this however this is a
point this would be a pointer to a
different area of memory because it's a
it's an array right especially cuz it's
varying sizes and you could make this
name be one by it long you can make it
be 50 bytes long you can make you be a
megabyte and then we have type and then
we have a pointer to data so we can't
just grab this anyway
so what we do need to do is happy to get
bytes how about that now we don't want
to do it this way this is one of the
ways that this is what I talked about in
the sterilization writer we could return
new byte array every time which would
mean that we allocate memory every time
fill that memory and then in the end we
would need to copy it into our actual
stream anyway so that's terrible we want
to do it this way which is where we
simply take in a pointer to where we are
in the byte thing and we write it in
right so we take in in this case the
array of bytes and then a pointer to
where we are in that array of bytes and
then what value to write so this is kind
of what we want to do again really
simple to do we do need to have a static
import Teucer ization writer so if i
just import static into field you will
get that and then all I'm going to do is
this will return an int right as say
again this is gonna look the same the
same it's gonna look the same as as what
it does here it returns an int and it's
gonna take in these parameters only
these two okay
and then what it's going to do is write
everything down so how's it going to do
that well glad you asked so first of all
the first thing it'll write is course
destination pointer plus plus at the end
we can return pointer oops the
difference and what that does we will
write BNE the container type
then we will write the name length so
again this is why we need this
realization writer because this is where
it gets fun because now we're kind of
combining we're actually writing
primitives not just single single bytes
which is what we did over here we were a
single bytes so we want to call write
bytes the destination being the
destination the point of being whatever
pointer is and of course pointer will be
assigned back to that and then the value
that we're writing in this case is going
to be named length so written name
length and then I guess we can if we
look at ride bytes
I believe we wrote one of these for a
byte array didn't we I hope we did did
it we I'll even write one for string so
we do have one for string that's cool
oh yes we did up here so this kind of
write bytes thing is what we're also
going to use but that's what was it was
what are they saying in reference to
what oh that's right because we're
writing the name that now so if we just
do name
that's a byte array then it should do
this and it will yeah okay so that was
probably a movement at either just
making sure then we'll write the type so
you can see how easy this is right we
could even you know what for
consistency's sake let's also write
container type using that I mean we
might as well daughter okay that's it
and then we could just return pointer
that has filled up our destination
buffer with all of the data that makes
up a field okay you guys could probably
kind of see how this whole sterilization
thing works now it's going to be a lot
more of this okay reading it is going to
be an entirely different beast and we'll
obviously cover that but the writing
part of it is a lot easier than reading
especially wants to define once you've
decided on a concrete kind of
implementation like once you have a
design that you know is good you're
ready to go so let's test this out as we
always do it's got a nice ability from
by spiders run this real quick okay
that'll just print that I guess is that
what we expected
this will just print that so I just want
to see print by its data okay so that
I'll just print that that's a bit
annoying but okay sure fine whatever
let's carry this so field field equals
new field field dot container type so
this is going to be again we can create
a subclass this we don't really need to
in this case I think I will make a
constructor that just takes in a
container type oh sorry I should mention
the container type is always going to be
type dot field of course or container
type dot field because because yeah it's
a field right so this this is easy we
can make this static final and you know
if we want it to be really cool we could
bring up the container type to be cap so
that we know it's it's it's final
however we also get like set name we can
do I guess and then obviously stuff like
setting integers and stuff because of
the actual data that it is that can it
be a bit difficult I wonder if there's a
better way to do that you could provide
you know what I'm just thinking if
there's a way to template this or to
make this a generic class there might be
the problem is can we reliably get oh
actually there should be shouldn't there
as long as we've got every single
possible implementation yeah and there
really isn't because Java all right
let's for example write out an integer
so I'll create an INT field which
extends field I don't know what I'm
doing it by the way we're just gonna see
if this works out
then an infield would just really
probably take in an int string name in
start value and then what that could do
is get out this thing going
data this also means that we have to
copy data unfortunately I kind of did
want to avoid that but we'll go from
Alice's why I had the type getsize type
int right by it's our destination being
data pointed thing zero value being
value and then the name of course we
have to run set name name and that's it
so this is just kind of almost like a
little convenience you could be you
could do something like set int or
something like that but again since we
do need a new field every time this will
probably work out better anyway we'll do
something like new in field tests and
eight okay we'll put that and then we
can print out field get bytes so we will
have our byte array data equals new
bytes doing a heartbeat this needs to be
we also don't know how big this needs to
be which is annoying I mean do we need
to know how big this thing is
we'll just say 100 for now we'll talk
about sizes those on me next time get
five starter zero
I've gonna print bytes is it that
returns an int apparently oh of course
yeah so data okay so let's see what
happens here we probably get a lot yeah
okay so there that's the end I believe
that should be the end so these are the
bytes that we got let's just pop them
here let's take a look at what they are
looking at the structure we know what we
know what they are anyway but we've got
the contain entire which is filled of
course that should result in a single
byte that is set to one filled one
that's the first byte that we have then
we have the name length which is a true
by it short and that should be the
length of test which would be four
characters so that those are the two
bytes that describe that right and then
we have this stuff which looks a bit
weird that's actually the four
characters I assume T est you can see
that they do like I was gonna say they
match but they don't because one's a lot
case ones upper case but tes capital T
log s es and T then we should have the
type which we haven't set which is why
it's set to zero and then after that we
have the actual data which should be
four bytes and they should result in
eight okay
there you go there's our field one thing
I should mention is that we did not set
the type unfortunately so if we do so
the type by just saying ty pickles
type dot int then the only thing we
should see is that if this is our
current thing without type we should see
this byte over here be set to like four
or something right where's type gum for
okay so I was running the N and you can
see now if I compare these two we have
the fall okay which means it's an
integer
okay cool so that wraps up this video
hopefully you learnt something if you
did please hit like button on the video
I should mention also that yeah that
this is pretty much all it takes to
write out fields next time we might
create more of these self classes I kind
of like that idea the other thing I'm a
little bit skeptical about is this whole
bad allocation thing if we could somehow
avoid that which we can technically then
that would be a lot better
it's just that I'm I'm thinking about
whether or not there is an actual
optimized way to do that in Java because
if this was you know C++ we would simply
store a pointer to the value which I
mean yeah the other thing is in this
case it's actually going to be pretty
much indistinguishable whether or not we
copy this data because it is a primitive
type right 4 bytes is nothing it's okay
to allocate something that's 4 bytes
like if we had a if we had like a
reference to it or something and then
that would also be 4 bytes on a 32-bit
system so it's fine right I think that
this is going to work we're gonna get
away with this
for something like strings that could be
several hundred bytes or something long
probably not the best idea certainly not
for arrays
probably not objects but for primitive
types I think copying data and creating
actual new allocated memory is fine all
right anyway thanks for watching guys
hope you enjoy that video if you did and
you really liked it you can support me
on patreon like home falls that is it
sure no that'll just make that'll just
help me make more videos really and if
that's something you're interested in
then you should probably become a
patreon alright guys thanks for watching
I'll see you next time goodbye